ok
à
monsieur schwan vous êtes président du
syndicat des vignerons puis il convient
de vignerons êtes vous maintenant oui et
bien une 152 habitants et environ 110 ou
syndicales
y at il eu toujours des vignobles
dépouillé de tout temps de te temps des
temps les plus reculés on a toujours
cultivé la vigne est ce que vous pouvez
donner des dates est bien entouré il a
depuis 841 est elle à 12/100 même 12
100es alors la vie était prospère
environs des années 1840 à 1860 il y
avait dans les cinq ministères des mines
d'emplois est aujourd'hui combien
d'étapes de 480 assassin à quelle date
de récolte rambouillet sur le variable
suivant les années en 50 ans par exemple
on a commencé le 22 22 septembre 25
septembre et alors qu'en 60 où on n'aura
plus la bête on a compris pendant des
années on a commencé le 25 octobre
c'est très variable c'est ça c'est
l'état qui décide
vigneron et son métier point je me suis
inscris métier qui serait rentable seule
maman se laissera commission guy conrady
recon d'abord c'est le propre gardien
mais ensuite que le vaincu le vin rival
niçois a payé après la zone ap
et surtout c'est le premier jour qui se
veut que vous vous assurez chili je
n'avais l'état sur du pain des vieux une
retraite normale il serait pas d'origine
il serait certainement de terre surtout
et avec à l'isolation qui existe depuis
six ans
depuis je dors leurrer la loi la loi qui
foulent ici et qu'on le soleil world
karachi chaîne rooney manquera d'il y a
que les fous pour baptiser leur égard
depuis vous pouvez toujours voir sa loi
tous les soucis bien mieux que le de
loire ont rejoint berry si le vous
sépare le bon vin rouge unis sous son
étendard de tous les produits de notre
terroir
c'est lui mes amis qui me fait notre
joie
bien que vers les deux quiz nous chasser
idée loin
orange a déjà pu nous coûter ce nouveau
ram est fantomatique donc deux rationnés
comme cette année
oui nos fumées 1966 voir comment ils se
comportent ils de soutirer la rivière
dizaine de jours il s'active
oui les petits tricycles rire quand
j'entends mme suu kyi il a quand même un
peu de fruits et bon tu veux bien reposé
bienvenus il évoque les frites et les
séquelles remarque comment s'y dit effet
autour de cinq et demi ça va à peu près
complet bien comme degré il faut être
aveugle complet sur le marché
tu as commencé à mettre en bouteille de
nouveaux mentors pour évidemment entendu
faire davantage de boue c'est dur d'être
mis en danger
je pense que celle-ci ainsi peuple ou
quelque chose oui non enfin de l'estran
oui c'est peut-être aussi parce que ça
vient d'une ligne un peu plus vieille
défaite un peu moins chargée est déjà
bien tomber un week-end entier
avant on avait des chocs avant lorsque
je sors de là dessus et quelques
origines
6 octobre - j mais j'ai un pôle des
jeunes ça fait trois points c'est bon
mais il ya pas longtemps qu'il se
retirait dans ce délai les montures gens
là gros de fruits
compte tenu que vous êtes inquiétés